En 1962, après la lecture du "Printemps Silencieux" de Rachel Carson,
pour beaucoup de créateurs comme moi, je pense,
le canari dans la mine s'est arrêté de chanter.
et le risque de la disparition des oiseaux par l'utilisation des pesticides
est devenue fondamentale pour ceux qui comme moi
cherchaient les passereaux qui avaient l'air d'avoir disparus.
La question était: les oiseaux continueraient-ils de chanter ?
Soyons clair, je ne suis pas un scientifique.
Mais nous venons d'avoir cette discussion sur ce qu'est un oiseau.
Qu'est-ce qu'un oiseau au juste ?
Eh bien, dans mon monde, c’est un canard en plastique.
Il est livré en Californie avec une notice où on peut lire :
"Ce produit contient des produits chimiques reconnus par l'état de Californie
comme cancérigènes, mutagènes et repro-toxiques (CMR)."
Ceci est un oiseau.
Quel genre de culture est capable de produire un produit de ce genre,
de l'étiqueter ainsi et de le vendre aux enfants ?
Je pense que nous avons un problème de conception.
Quelqu'un qui avait écouté les 6 heures de conférence que j'ai tenues à la radio
intitulées "Les Dialogues de Monticello", m'a envoyé cette note de remerciement :
"Nous réalisons que le design est un signal d’intention,
mais qu’il est émis dans un monde,
et nous devons comprendre ce monde pour pouvoir
insuffler à nos créations une intelligence inhérente,
et si nous analysons notre état d'esprit lors de cette phase de conception
nous devons d'une certaine manière revenir à la condition primordiale
qui est de comprendre le système opérationnel et les conditions contextuelles d'une planète,
et je pense que cela est une bonne et excitante nouvelle,
car nous parlons là d'une annonce d'abondance,
et non une annonce de limitations,
et je pense que tandis que notre culture est en train de se torturer
avec des tyrannies et des soucis sur les limitations et la peur,
nous pouvons ajouter cette nouvelle dimension d'abondance, cohérente,
régie par le soleil, et commencer à imaginer
ce que pourrait être le partage."
C'était une note plaisante à recevoir.
C'était une seule phrase.
Henry James en serait fier.
Voilà... je l'ai mis en bas,
évidemment de manière impromptue...
Voilà le problème fondamental pour moi :
le design est le premier signal des intentions humaines.
Donc quelles sont nos intentions, et quelles seraient-elles --
imaginons qu'on se réveille un matin pour concevoir notre monde --
quelle serait notre intention en tant qu'espèce,
maintenant que nous sommes l'espèce dominante ?
Et je ne parle pas juste du débat entre intendance et domination,
car en fait, la domination est implicite dans l'intendance --
car comment dominer quelque chose que vous avez tué ?
Et l'intendance est implicite dans la domination,
car vous ne pouvez être l'intendant de quelque chose si vous ne le dominez pas.
La question est donc, quelle doit-être la première question d'un designer ?
Si on considère les gardiens -- par exemple l'Etat,
qui se réserve le droit de tuer, de duplicité, etc. --
la question qu'on pose au gardien est :
est-on sensé, et comment peut-on à la fois,
sécuriser nos sociétés, maintenir la paix dans le monde
et sauver l'environnement ?
Mais je ne sais pas si c'est le débat.
Le marché, d'un autre côté, est relativement rapide,
essentiellement créatif, hautement efficace et efficient,
et fondamentalement honnête, parce qu'il ne peut
y avoir d'échange dans la durée sans confiance.
Nous utilisons donc principalement le marché pour notre travail,
mais la question devient alors :
comment peut-on aimer tous les descendants de toutes les espèces pour toujours ?
Alors on commence nos réflexions avec cette question.
Parce nous réalisons aujourd'hui que notre culture moderne
a l'air d'avoir adopté une stratégie tragique.
Si on arrive ici en disant "Eh bien, je n'avais pas l'intention
de contribuer au réchauffement climatique en arrivant ici",
et qu’on dit, "Cela ne fait pas partie de mon plan",
on réalise alors que cela fait partie de notre plan implicite.
Parce que cela se produit ainsi car nous n'avons pas d'autre plan.
J'étais à la Maison Blanche avec le président Bush,
j'ai rencontré chaque département et agence fédérale,
et je leur ai fait remarquer qu'ils n'avaient l'air d'avoir aucun plan.
Si le but du jeu c’est le réchauffement climatique, ils se débrouillent très bien
Si le but du jeu c’est l'intoxication au mercure de nos enfants
à proximité des centrales au charbon tout en sabotant les lois sur la qualité de l’air du Clean Air Act,
alors je propose que nos programmes d'éducation soit explicitement définis ainsi :
"Aucun enfant au bord du chemin, la mort cérébrale pour tous"
(Applaudissements)
Donc la question est : combien de fonctionnaires fédéraux
sont prêts à déménager en Ohio et en Pennsylvanie avec leurs familles ?
Si vous n'avez pas une finalité bénéfique,
alors vous ne faites que déplacer vos pions au hasard
sans savoir qu'il faut faire échec au roi.
Peut-être que nous pourrions développer une stratégie de changement
qui nécessite de l'humilité. Et en tant qu'architecte,
je trouve dommage que le mot "humilité" et le mot "architecte"
ne soient pas apparus dans le même paragraphe depuis "La Source Vive".
Si certains ont des problèmes avec le concept d'humilité en matière de design,
n'oubliez pas qu'il nous a fallu 5000 ans
pour rajouter des roues à nos valises.
Donc, comme l'indiquait Kevin Kelly, il n'y a pas de but du jeu.
Nous jouons à un jeu infini.
Et nous l'appelons : "du berceau au berceau" (Cradle To Cradle)
et notre objectif est très simple.
C'est cela que j'ai présenté à la Maison Blanche.
Notre objectif est un monde délicieusement varié, sûr, en bonne santé, et juste,
avec de l'air pur, de l'eau pure, un sol pur, de l'énergie propre --
économiquement, équitablement, écologiquement et élégamment agréable, point final.
(Applaudissements)
Comment ne pas être d'accord avec ça ?
Y-a-t'il une seule partie avec laquelle on peut ne pas être d'accord ?
Nous avons compris que nous voulons une pleine et entière diversité,
même s'il est difficile de se rappeler ce que De Gaulle a répondu
lorsqu'on lui a demandé ce que c'était d'être Président de la France.
Il a dit : "Comment voulez-vous gouverner un pays où il existe 258 variétés de fromage ?"
Mais en même temps, nous comprenons que nos produits ne sont pas sûrs et sains.
Donc nous avons conçu des produits
et nous avons analysé leur composition chimique à un niveau très fin.
Ceci est une couverture pour bébé par Pendleton qui donnera matière à vivre à votre bébé
plutôt qu’Alzheimer plus tard.
On peut se demander, qu'est-ce que la justice,
et la justice est-elle aveugle, ou bien est-elle l’aveuglement ?
A quel moment est-ce que cet uniforme blanc est-il devenu noir ?
Les Nations Unies ont déclaré que l'eau est un droit de l'homme.
La qualité de l'air est essentielle pour quiconque respire.
Y-a-t'il quelqu'un ici qui ne respire pas ?
Un sol pur est un problème critique - la nitrification,
les zones mortes dans le Golfe du Mexique.
Un problème fondamental dont personne ne s'occupe.
On a vu apparaître la première forme d'énergie solaire
qui combat l'hégémonie des carburants fossiles sous la forme du vent
ici dans les Grandes Plaines, et cette hégémonie va disparaître.
Souvenons-nous de Sheikh Yamani lorsqu'il créa l'OPEP,
on lui demanda : "Quand verrons-nous la fin de l'âge du pétrole ?"
Je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez de sa réponse :
"L'âge de pierre ne s'est pas terminé parce qu'on est arrivé à court de pierres".
On voit bien que les sociétés qui agissent de manière éthique envers ce monde
sont plus performantes que celles qui ne le font pas.
On voit dans les flux de matières premières des perspectives effrayantes.
Ceci est un moniteur d'hôpital de Los Angeles, envoyé en Chine.
Cette femme va s'exposer à du phosphore toxique,
et relâcher deux kilos de plomb toxique dans l'environnement où vivent ses enfants,
qui provient du cuivre.
Par ailleurs on voit également de grands signes d'espoir.
Voici le docteur Venkataswamy en Inde, qui a trouvé
comment faire passer dans la production de masse les questions de santé.
Il a rendu la vue à deux millions de personnes gratuitement.
On voit dans le flux des matériaux que l'acier des voitures ne peut être recyclé en acier automobile
à cause des produits toxiques des revêtements --
bismuth, antimoine, cuivre, etc.
On le recycle en acier de construction.
Par ailleurs, nous travaillons avec Berkshire Hathaway,
Warren Buffett et Shaw Carpet,
la plus grande société de production de moquette du monde.
Nous avons développé une moquette continuellement recyclable,
jusqu'à ses plus simples composants.
Le dessus c'est du Nylon 6 qui peut redevenir du caprolactame,
le dessous un polyolephine - un polymère thermoplastique infiniment recyclable.
Si j'étais un oiseau, l'immeuble à ma gauche serait un obstacle.
L'immeuble à ma droite, le campus de la société The Gap,
avec une ancienne prairie, serait un atout - un lieu de nidification.
Voilà d'où je viens. J'ai grandi à Hong Kong,
avec 6 millions de personnes sur 100 km².
Pendant la saison sèche, on avait 4h d'eau courante tous les 4 jours.
Et le paysage était issu du travail des fermiers qui ont
entretenu la même terre pendant 40 siècles.
On ne cultive pas la même terre pendant 40 siècles
sans comprendre les flux de nutriments.
Enfant, j'ai passé mes étés dans le Puget Sound de l'Etat de Washington,
parmi les jeunes pousses et les grands arbres.
Mon grand-père était un bûcheron dans les Olympic Moutains,
donc j’ai plein de karma forestier dont je dois me détacher.
J'ai été diplomé à Yale,
j'ai étudié dans un bâtiment de ce genre conçu par Le Corbusier,
genre à qui l'on donne dans le métier le nom affectueux de Brutalisme.
Si on regarde le monde de l'architecture,
on regarde cette tour conçu en 1928 par Mies pour Berlin,
on peut se poser la question "Où est le soleil ?"
Et ça aurait pu marcher à Berlin, mais on l'a construite à Houston,
et les fenêtres ne peuvent pas s'ouvrir. Et comme la plupart des productions
qui n’ont pas été conçues pour ceux qui sont dedans,
c’est en réalité un four vertical.
Pendant que j'étais à Yale, nous avons connu la première crise énergétique,
et j'ai conçu la première maison solaire en Irlande
en tant qu'étudiant, que j'ai ensuite construite --
cela vous donne une mesure de mon ambition.
Et Richard Meiers, qui était l'un de mes professeurs,
venait tout le temps me voir pour me critiquer,
et il disait : "Bill, il faut que vous compreniez --
l'énergie solaire n'a rien à voir avec l'architecture."
Je pense qu'il n'a jamais lu Vitruve.
En 1984, nous avons conçu le premier "bureau vert" en Amérique
pour l’organisation Environmental Defense.
Nous avons commencé à demander aux constructeurs la composition de leurs matériaux.
Ils nous ont répondu : "Ils sont propriétaires, ils sont protégés, allez-vous-en."
La seule étude de qualité de vie dans les bâtiments ayant été faite dans le pays à ce moment-là
avait été commanditée par R.J. Reynolds Tobacco Company
et démontrait que le tabagisme passif
était sans danger sur les lieux de travail.
Donc je me retrouve diplômé en 1969, et avec le premier homme sur la lune
et les photos de la Terre, on réalise que "l’ailleurs" n’a plus cours.
Vous vous souvenez comment on jetait les choses ailleurs, comment on pensait à ailleurs ?
et pourtant, l'Agence Nationale pour l'Océan et l'Atmosphère (NOAA)
nous a montré ce petit truc bleu au-dessus d'Hawaii.
C'est le Grand vortex du Pacifique Nord.
Des scientifiques ont récemment analysé les eaux à cet endroit
et ont trouvé six fois plus de plastique que de plancton.
Ils ont dit "C'est comme un WC géant sans chasse d'eau".
C'est ça, ailleurs.
Donc on cherche à comprendre le modèle de conception derrière ça --
c'est l'endroit avec la plus grande biodiversité au monde, Irian Jaya,
259 espèces d'arbres, et nous l'avons décrit
dans le livre "Du Berceau au Berceau".
Ce livre est en polymère. Ce n'est pas un arbre.
C'est le titre du premier chapitre -- "Ce Livre N'est Pas un Arbre".
Car poétiquement, comme l'a dit Margaret Atwood,
"nous écrivons notre histoire sur la peau des poissons
avec le sang des ours."
Et avec tant de polymères, ce donc nous avons besoin
c'est d'une nutrition technique, et utiliser quelque chose
d'aussi élégant qu'un arbre -- imaginez cette mission :
Concevez quelque chose qui produit de l'oxygène, agglomère le carbone,
utilise de l'azote, distille l'eau, utilise l'énergie solaire comme carburant,
crée des sucres et nutriments complexes, crée des micro-climats,
change de couleur avec les saisons et s'auto-reproduit.
Bon, on va l'abattre et écrire dessus.
(Rires)
Donc nous avons les mêmes critères
que la plupart des gens -- est-ce que je peux me l'offrir ?
Est-ce que ça marche ? Est-ce que ça me plaît ?
Nous ajoutons l'agenda Jeffersonien, et je viens de Charlottesville,
où j'ai eu le privilège de vivre dans une maison conçue par Thomas Jefferson.
Nous ajoutons la vie, la liberté et la poursuite du bonheur.
Maintenant, si on regarde le mot compétition,
Je suis sûr que vous l'avez tous déjà utilisé.
La plupart des gens ne savent pas que ce mot provient
du latin competare, qui signifie lutter ensemble.
Il fait référence aux entrainements des athlètes olympiques qui luttaient entre eux.
Ils s'aguerrissaient ensemble, puis ils faisaient la compétition.
Les sœurs Williams entrent en lice -- l'une gagne Wimbledon.
Donc nous considérons la compétition
comme une manière de coopérer pour s'améliorer ensemble.
Et le gouvernement chinois --
avec lequel je travaille maintenant --
avance dans cette optique.
Nous considérons également la survie du plus apte,
pas seulement dans le contexte de compétition moderne
où on détruit l'autre ou on le met à terre,
mais également comme une manière de s'adapter et de constituer des niches
et de croître de manière bénéfique et mutelle.
La plupart des écologistes ne disent pourtant pas que la croissance est bénéfique,
parce que, dans notre dictionnaire, asphalte est synonyme de honte.
Mais si on considère l'asphalte comme le symbole de notre croissance,
on comprend que ce que nous faisons c'est détruire
le système d’exploitation fondamental de notre planète.
Donc quand on regarde E=mc² avec un oeil de poète,
on voit que l'énergie c'est la physique, la chimie c'est la masse,
et tout à coup on obtient la biologie.
Et nous avons plein d'énergie, donc nous pouvons résoudre ce problème,
mais le problème de la biologie est complexe,
car avec tous ces matériaux toxiques que nous produisons,
on ne pourra jamais rattraper cela
Et comme l'a fait remarquer Francis Crick, neuf ans
après avoir découvert l'ADN avec M. Watson,
la vie elle-même a besoin de croissance,
elle a besoin d'énergie abondante, le soleil,
et elle a besoin d'un système ouvert de substances chimiques.
Donc nous demandons que les constructions humaines deviennent des organismes vivants,
et nous voulons de la croissance, de l'énergie abondante du soleil,
et nous voulons un métabolisme ouvert aux substances chimiques.
Alors la question n'est plus croissance ou décroissance,
mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire croître.
Et plutôt que faire croître la destruction,
nous voulons faire croître des choses dont nous pouvons profiter,
et un jour la FDA nous permettra de fabriquer du fromage français.
Donc nous avons deux systèmes métaboliques
et j'ai travaillé avec un chimiste allemand, Michael Braugart,
et nous avons identifié les deux métabolismes fondamentaux.
Je suis sûr que vous comprenez le métabolisme biologique,
mais nous avons également le métabolisme technique, où nous créons des matériaux
et nous les mettons dans un cycle fermé.
Nous appelons cela nutrition biologique et nutrition technique.
La nutrition technique sera d'un autre ordre de grandeur rapport à la nutrition biologique.
La nutrition biologique permet d'entretenir environ 500 millions d'êtres humains,
ce qui signifie que si on portait tous des Birkenstocks et du coton,
on épuiserait très vite nos ressources en liège et en eau.
On a donc besoin de matériaux en cycles fermés,
mais il faut analyser leur composition pour évaluer
les risques de cancer, de malformations à la naissance, d'effets mutagènes,
d'atteinte au système immunitaire, la durée de biodégratation,
leur contenu en métaux lourds, la connaissance de
leur processus de production, etc.
Notre premier produit était un textile issu de l'analyse
de 9800 produits chimiques de l'industrie textile.
Avec les règles explicitées, nous en avons éliminé 9762.
Il ne nous en restait que 38.
Nous avons créé une base de données des 4000 produits chimiques
les plus utilisés dans l'industrie, que nous publierons dans 6 semaines,
pour que les concepteurs du monde entier puissent analyser leurs produits
et en déduire leur impact sur la santé humaine et leur impact écologique.
(Applaudissements)
Nous avons développé un protocole pour que les sociétés envoient
ces mêmes messages à travers toutes leurs chaînes de fournisseurs,
parce que nous avons interrogé celles avec lesquelles nous travaillons -- elles représentent environ 1000 milliards de dollars
-- et lorsqu'on leur demande "D'où viennent vos produits", on nous répond : "Des fournisseurs".
"Et où vont-ils ?"
"Chez les clients."
Donc on a besoin d'aide là.
Avec les nutriments biologiques, lors de la fabrication des premiers tissus,
l'eau issue de la production était potable.
Avec les nutriments techniques, on obtient la moquette recyclable à l’infini de Shaw Carpet,
du nylon qui redevient du caprolactame qui redevient de la moquette.
Des nutriments biotechniques -- le concept-car Model U de Ford,
une voiture "du berceau au berceau".
Des chaussures de Nike, avec un dessus en polyester recyclable,
et des semelles biodégradables.
Usez vos vieilles chaussures et faites-en des nouvelles.
C'est une course sans ligne d'arrivée.
L'idée de cette voiture est que certains matériaux sont
réutilisés à l'infini dans l'industrie, d'autres retournent dans le sol --
et elle est alimentée par l'énergie solaire.
Voici un immeuble que nous avons conçu à Oberlin College
qui produit plus d'énergie qu'il en consomme et purifie sa propre eau.
Voici un immeuble pour The Gap, où nous avons replanté
les prairies de San Bruno, Californie, sur le toit.
Voici notre projet pour Ford,
le réaménagement écologique de la Rivière Rouge à Dearborn.
C'est une photo en couleur.
Voici nos outils. Voici comment on l'a vendu à Ford.
Nous avons permis à Ford d'économiser 35 millions de dollar dès le premier jour,
ce qui est équivalent à une commande pour 900 millions de Ford Taurus
avec une marge de 4%.
Le voilà. C'est le plus grand toit vert du monde, 4 hectares.
Voici le toit qui est en train d'économiser de l'argent,
et voici la première espèce à emménager. Des pluviers kildir.
Ils sont arrivés au bout de 5 jours.
Et maintenant nous avons des ouvriers de 150 kilos
qui apprennent les chants des oiseaux sur internet.
Nous développons maintenant des protocoles pour des villes --
c’est la maison-mère des nutriments techniques.
En face, la campagne biologique. Et nous les unifions.
Je vais donc finir en vous montrant cette ville nouvelle
que nous sommes en train de concevoir pour le gouvernement chinois.
Nous développons 12 villes en Chine actuellement,
en partant des concepts "du berceau au berceau".
Notre mission est de développer un projet pour héberger
400 millions de personnes dans 12 ans.
Nous avons fait des calculs -- s’ils utilisent des briques,
ils épuiseront tout leur sol et tout leur charbon.
Ils auront des villes sans énergie et sans nourriture.
Nous avons signé un accord --
ici avec Madame Deng Lan, la fille de Deng Xiaoping --
pour que la Chine adopte le concept "du berceau au berceau".
Parce que s'ils s'intoxiquent eux-mêmes, étant le producteur le moins cher,
ils enverront cela au distributeur le moins cher -- Wal-Mart --
et alors nous leur enverrons tout notre argent,
et nous obtiendrons ce qu'on appelait quand j'étais étudiant
une destruction mutuelle assurée.
Nous les concevons au niveau moléculaire. Voici nos villes.
Nous construisons une nouvelle ville à côté de cette ville-là. Regardez le paysage.
Voici le site.
Normalement on ne s'occupe pas des espaces verts, mais celui-là allait être construit,
donc ils ont fait appel à nous.
Voici leur plan.
Un croisillement arbitraire posé sur ce paysage.
Ils nous ont appelé et ont demandé: "Que pouvons nous faire ?"
Voici ce qu'ils auraient obtenu, une autre photo en couleur.
Voici donc à quoi ressemble le site actuel,
et voici notre proposition.
(Applaudissements)
Notre méthode pour ce projet
a été d'étudier soigneusement l'hydrologie.
Nous avons étudié l'écosystème, passé et présent,
le mode de culture actuel.
Nous avons étudié les vents et le soleil pour nous assurer que chacun dans la ville
aura de l'air frais, de l'eau fraiche et bénéficiera directement de la lumière du soleil
dans chaque appartement à un moment de la journée.
Nous avons ensuite défini les parcs comme notre infrastructure écologique.
Nous avons alors défini les zones d'habitation.
Nous avons intégré des zones commerciales et des zones mixtes
pour que chacun ait des espaces commerciaux et de bureau à proximité.
Les transports sont très simples,
tout est accessible à tout le monde à 5 minutes de marche.
Nous avons une rue où tout est ouvert 24h/24 pour qu'il y ait toujours un endroit animé.
Tous les systèmes de déchets sont connectés.
Quand vous tirez la chasse d'eau, vos déjections sont acheminées dans des usines de retraitement
qui sont des atouts et non des dettes pour les municipalités.
Car qui veut d'une usine d’engrais qui fait du gaz naturel ?
Les eaux usées sont acheminées vers des zones humides et restaurées.
Et on y produit du gaz naturel, qui est renvoyé vers la ville
comme gaz de cuisine.
Voici les usines d’engrais.
Ensuite tout le compost est ramené
sur les toits de la ville, où on trouve des cultures,
car nous avons tout simplement soulevé le paysage
en l'air pour rétablir le paysage natif
sur les toits de la ville.
Des panneaux solaires sur toutes les usines
et tous les toits des zones industrielles produisent l'électricité de la ville.
Et voici à quoi ressemblera le haut de la ville.
Nous avons soulevé la terre sur les toits.
Les fermiers auront des ponts pour passer d'un toit à l'autre.
Nous habitons la ville avec des espaces de vie et de travail sur tous les niveaux.
Voici la ville actuelle, et voici la nouvelle ville.
(Applaudissements)